thank you Mr Hansen now after these
opening words I would like to ask your
attention for the president of the
European commission she will share her
thoughts and experiences on the
Strategic Partnership of the EU and the
asean based on the shared values and
principles of both organizations Her
Excellency Mrs Ursula Van Der Lane who I
will also ask to join at this lectern
foreign
[Applause]
highness fellow leaders
let me add my warm welcome to Brussels
after such a long trip
one thing is for sure
there might be many many miles that
divide us
but they are much more values that unite
us
for 45 years now indeed ties between the
European Union and asean have grown
stronger and stronger
and today our strategic partnership is
more relevant than ever
because if we literally stand at the
opposite sides of the world
our Destinies are linked more than ever
before
we have seen it with a pandemic
we see it in the connections of our
value chains
we see it with climate change
and with geopolitics
Russia's war against Ukraine has sent
shock waves through the world
not only is it an attack against the
rules-based order
which protects every country's right at
all corners of the world
Russia's war of aggression has also
destabilized the global economy and made
global commodity prices soar
I know that asean has just signed with
Ukraine the Treaty of Amity and
cooperation and this speaks louder than
a million words
fellow leaders both the European Union
and asean have multilateralism in our
DNA
we have strong economic ties
we have a similar outlook on the
indo-pacific
and this Summit gives the opportunity to
discuss how we can join forces even more
to achieve our shared goals and I3 see
three key areas where we can do more
the first is on energy and climate
Russia has Unleashed a global energy
crisis
which comes on top
of the ongoing climate crisis
to both crises is
same
we must
our transition away from fossil fuels
and towards renewable energy
renewable energy is not only good for
the climate
but it is also homegrown it gives us
independence and security of supply
20 in Bali we signed a Just Energy
transition partnership
with Indonesia
and together with Partners we have just
concluded a similar partnership with
Vietnam
I know that prime minister Hun Sen has
called for an asean green deal
so let us discuss how the European green
deal and the asean green deal can
reinforce each other
my second point
we should also reinforce our economic
ties and trade
we are each other's third largest
trading partner but
it accounts only for five percent of our
trade so there's so much of untapped
potential
and the lesson of the pandemic should be
that we should all diversify our
Partnerships
and we all know that today
trade agreements are much more than
tariffs and quotas
they are vehicles of cooperation
who jointly address the twin green and
digital transitions
they are also about digital trade
about clean Technologies
about resilient Supply chains
I very much welcome that our trade
ministers focus on that now
our trade agreements with Singapore and
Vietnam are already delivering on the
ground
and Europe wants to conclude more free
trade agreements with other asean
countries
our ultimate goal is
one of the region to region agreement
and I think we need to seize now the
opportunity and make it work
my third and final point
meeting the challenges of the twin green
and digital transition requires massive
investments in infrastructure and people
and we all need to diversify our sources
of investment
many investments will be private
and some will require public support to
make them happen
and this is where global gateway comes
into play
and today team Europe is putting forward
an investment package for asean worth 10
billion euros until 2027.
if we want to link our zones of growth
we need to upgrade our economies
great clean energy the digital
infrastructure from wind farms to solar
power plants
we will support the integration of
electricity infrastructure
and electricity markets in asean
and we will invest in trust it and
secure digital submarine connections
we will cooperate on Research
and on academic exchange programs
thought of good work ahead of us for
both Europe and Southeast Asia once
again a very warm welcome to Brussels
[Applause]